décidément rien ne va en ce moment pour
Jean-Michel Blanquer après avoir été
remercié de son ministère de l'Éducation
nationale et remplacée par Papen DIY
l'ex-minis qui était en campagne pour
les législatives ce week-end à Montargis
s'est fait asperger de crème chantilly
par deux enseignants en colère
de 51 et 57 ans expliqué à travers une
vidéo que leur gestes n’était pas
prémédité et qu'il souhaitait dénoncer
un bilan critique violentes la chantilly
la violence c'est 12% d'élèves qui
arrivent en 6e et qui ne sont pas
capables de lire ou de comprendre un
texte ils devront comparaître le 4
juillet prochain pour violence en
réunion n'ayant pas entraîné
d'incapacité totale de travail alors
Jean-Michel Blanquer a-t-il raison de
porter plainte contre les deux profs qui
l'ont entarter
alors est-ce qu'il a eu raison de porter
plainte alors ça reste ça reste alors
c'est de la chantilly donc c'est pas
dangereux mais ça reste une agression
mais oui voilà
l'exemple donc qu'est-ce qu'on dit aux
élèves alors après derrière
aujourd'hui on peut donner des gifles
aux gens entarter les gens si on peut je
veux dire aujourd'hui on a un problème
en France d'éducation il est là le
malaise c'est un problème d'éducation du
respect de l'état du respect de son
prochain du respect d'autrui donc si à
un moment donné des professeurs peuvent
se permettre de faire ça je m'en fous
qu'il soit ministre ancien ministre mais
peuvent faire ça comme ça pour donner
l'exemple je suis désolé je trouve ça
mais miséreux catastrophique
si la raison il a raison alors les
Guillaume vous n'êtes pas d'accord non
mais certes c'est pas bien dans ta un
ministre ou une personnalité publique
mais porter plainte c'est complètement
disproportionné oui ce sont des
professeurs mais posez-vous la question
pourquoi ils en arrivent à faire ça ils
sont dépités
par respecter il ne se font mais c'est
pas les Guillaume pardon ils ne se font
pas entendre dans les médias et leur
seul manière de se faire entendre c'est
faire des sortes de comme ça et la
preuve ça marche puisqu'on en parle donc
ce n'est pas bien mais je comprends leur
détresse et c'est pas très grave non
plus il y a des personnes
professeur il se passe quoi c'est normal
ou c'est pas normal
ce que je veux dire c'est que ce n'est
pas gratuit ils ont un message à faire
passer et personne ne les écoute
les libertés on peut s'exprimer
aujourd'hui on est obligé d'aller
entarter un passage
en même temps non mais Guillaume tu te
rends compte le monde que tu nous
proposes c'est à dire que dès qu'on est
pas d'accord avec quelqu'un
on lui envoie un message
ça aurait pu être une batte de baseball
ça peut être n'importe quoi
dans l'agression c'est pareil
c'est par des parents d'élèves à l'école
j'aimerais bien savoir si les
professeurs ne vont pas les porter
plainte
de dire à des élèves je suis le
professeur le respect on écoute on fait
les choses là je suis désolé qu'on aime
ou pas monsieur Blanquer à la limite on
interpelle et on parle avec lui c'est
pas pour autant
ça devient exactement comme dit Nico
c'est la jungle parce que bien heureux
qu'il est par rétorqué il y a un moment
alors c'est dans la rue j'aime pas tes
cheveux je te tends je te tends les
cheveux ou c'est on peut plus
aujourd'hui ça devient fou le monde
souffrance dans une grande détermination
ils vont tous agresser les autres mais
c'est pas vrai on a la petite vidéo des
des professeurs qui ont évidemment réagi
en plus
on regarde la vidéo on en parle après
l'éducation nationale a décidé d'engager
une procédure disciplinaire contre nous
nous avons été accueilli ce matin en
collège par un haut responsable de
l'éducation nationale et nos chefs
d'établissements respectifs l'affaire
chantilly est prise très au sérieux en
haut lieu la rapidité de la procédure
judiciaire déclenchée par le citoyen
blanc clair après la projection de
flocons de chantilly sur sa casquette
nous la prouvé procédure qui a mobilisé
ce samedi les plus hauts fonctionnaires
de l'État et des agents et officiers de
police déjà ont sous effectif
on est d'accord
sujet c'est pas le sujet je trouve qu'il
est minimise leur acte en disant oui il
a reçu quelques flocons de Chantilly
parce qu'ils l'ont un peu raté donc
voilà donc c'est arrivé un peu sur sa
casquette comme ça mais je trouve
qu'effectivement le fait de porter
plainte de toute façon cette plainte il
y aura pas très loin il y aura pas des
sanctions terribles
je pense pas mais c'est exemplaire ouais
il a raison de dire je ne peux pas
passer ça voilà il représente l'autorité
et c'est effectivement Guillaume a
raison c'est un acte politique il y a
d'autres manières de manifester des
actes politiques jamais ça va faire 20
ans jour pour jour si je vous dis en
partant
le groupe
ah oui ici qui nous avons vraiment une
star de l'entarthage
absolument
à l'époque moi j'étais comme je faisais
le loft il avait deux garde du corps
j'étais menacé tous les jours quand la
porte s'ouvre et que vous prenez la
table dans la gueule vous savez pas si
c'est effectivement une tarte ou si
c'est une batte de base c'était pareil
c'est à ça
c'est assez traumatisant maintenant ça
reste pas la lumière à tous les étages
et Bernard Henri Lévy à cette reprise
il voulait taper un moment est-ce qu'on
peut est-ce que la reine se fait
entarter
je pose la question
avec des œufs sur le carrosse de verre
c'était adresse
c'était en quelle année ça 92 la fameuse
qui part en fumeur
oui en fait faut entendre aussi ce que
disent ici les professeurs c'est qu'il y
a une justice à deux vitesses
c'est-à-dire que là tout va aller très
très vite pour une histoire de de
Chantilly et il y a des choses il y a
des viols il y a des crimes et ça prend
des années donc en fait c'est ça qu'il
faut comprendre et Guillaume je suis
d'accord avec toi il y a un malaise il y
a un manque de communication et il y a
des secteurs qui sont en détresse
l'éducation les profs sont en détresse
les infirmiers et la police voilà et et
en fait c'est la base qu'il faut
reprendre c'est toujours avec les
Français
est-ce que tu as pourquoi toujours un
policier envoyer de la chantilly attends
Gérald Darmanin arrivera jamais donc je
suis désolé mais c'est professeur c'est
une heure en plus d'avoir fait cette
vidéo où ils prennent ça à la légère
elle par ironie
prendre les bases ici on parle toujours
en fait des conséquences le problème
c'est que les lois le premier qui doit
être
content le problème c'est l'action
pardon alors à chaque fois les
politiques qui se prennent des trucs
dans la gueule quand c'est pas Zemmour
qui se prend je sais pas quoi ce qui
s'était pris il y a la gifle de Macron
Marine Le Pen avec Le Pen
c'est insupportable
extrêmement violent franchement
avec rien c'est scandaleux
je ne comprends pas que Delphine et
Guillaume le fasse franchement là je
suis scandalisé
le problème c'est qu'aujourd'hui en
France il y a les profs qui souffrent
les infirmiers qui souffrent
tout le monde
2022 les politiques devraient une fois
se remettre en question j'ai très bien
compris ce que tu dis c'est à dire
il y a des faits divers et le problème
c'est que nous on subit rien ne justifie
rien ne justifie une agressions
est-ce qu'on peut remettre la photo
derrière qui mettent le hashtag le
arobase professeur et du coup
immédiatisent leur truc et ils
deviennent des personnages viraux sur
les réseaux sociaux à part ça il souffre